Lauren Russell welcome to 21st century
living we have the ultimate comfort and
tranquility all suites have access to
our 24-hour surveillance of all key
venues the pinnacle is owned by a man
named Henning Dahlquist guy now check
this see what I can dig up a word just
last across the street won't work
Lauren Russell thinks you should be
hospitalized again plus if we don't get
results within four to six weeks I like
to try upping the dosage excuse me come
on how did you get through the gate and
I have to ask you to leave
this is the pinnacle or I will call
security have you noticed anything
unusual about your apartment what is
your interest in all this I met someone
recently who was talking about it
[Applause]
what if someone is using this building
has subliminal advertising experiment
coercive flash images this is not in my
head there's a party that can't be
touched you gotta listen to that part of
yourself you're not parent
do you trust
I'm operating would have frequency
outside the range of their attack the
exam panic that I think you can help me
prove it everything was straight-up
paranoia until
is it
my theory is a little Messier condition
takes over too much
hello Lauren
I should get up
when you are fully aware of what you've
done and then exactly what was asked of
me
you